what can you say about the crew you've
gotten the chance to meet them and talk
to them and Steve Aoki is on the crew
like who else who else is there so uh
you are obviously the the star athlete
who else in terms of the the artists
that are there so oh man we might just
want to pull up just so I don't totally
Butcher and forget anybody but because
so far I haven't actually had the chance
to meet everyone in person you know so
far a lot of this was done during the
pandemic but we've met through a couple
different things we've had a couple
different times to get together but so
so far I've not met Steve Aoki yet or
top
um we've been on calls and stuff I also
have not yet met uh Dev Joshi who is uh
an actor from India so yeah I mean Steve
Steve Aoki American uh DJ and producer
and musician top from South Korea is
also a musician and a producer so this
all across the world is a truly Global
uh all different kinds of walks of life
yeah all artists of different forms and
Steve is is Japanese uh his parents are
Japanese but he you know lit born raised
in the United States uh yemi is a dancer
and choreographer from the Czech
Republic uh Rhiannon is a fine art
photographer from well England in in
Ireland I guess she lives in both in
kind of a bit of a she's all over the
place uh Technically she's Irish I guess
uh I Tim Dodd yep that's me from the
United States uh uh then you have Kareem
who is from England and does also as a
photographer and documentarian uh does a
lot of work with oceanography and uh
volcanoes so he does really incredible
work Brendan Hall is a documentarian and
filmmaker Dev Joshi sorry Brendan is
also from the United States Dev Joshi is
an Indian actor
I believe also I believe he's also
already been producing and things he's
very young I think he's only like 19 or
20 and he's I mean he's been acting
since he was like five years old or
something he's a he's a Bollywood star
like he is a star in India which is
really cool right
um Caitlyn Farrington from the United
States is an Olympic gold medalist
snowboarder so she believe it or not is
the athlete not me
and then uh and she's one of the backup
crew members as as so is uh Miu from
Japan who's a dancer
oh it's amazing I mean it's such an
interesting group I mean can you is
there something else you could say about
MZ how about you you sakamaizawa so he
uh he's also a musician so he was
actually in like some kind of punk
hardcore Japanese bands in the early in
the 90s and stuff and early 2000s he
started a um a record company and and
distribution and sales ended up in in
fashion and um owns one of the biggest
fashion companies in Japan and has
become a fine art collector and just
kind of a philanthropist and and he's
been out to space already he's already
not only been to space like you know
he's been to the International Space
Station he's been on orbit and on the
ISS and so he what's cool is like you
know there's talks of when there's then
frankly to be to be honest and we still
don't I still don't know all of the
details about this you know we're not
yet into training I kind of always
assumed prior that there'd be some
professional astronaut you know when
they talked about in 2018 there's talks
of we'll have a professional astronaut
on board
but realistically now like MZ is a
trained astronaut you know he has
trained a lot like six months you know
plus to be able to fly on soyuz so as
far as like it's good to know for me
that I have someone
on the crew that has experience with
space flight
um has trained and has some knowledge on
space flight as well you know that's
that is an important aspect for sure so
you made a excellent video about flying
in the fighter jet uh that I think you
mentioned may be relevant uh to the
training is there some high level
aspects to training that you anticipate
that you might be able to speak to yeah
so you know so far I think we can really
lean on what has happened with the other
um you know commercial crew missions and
in in private missions like the
inspiration form Mission or Axiom uh
where SpaceX flew individually they
trained for about six months a lot of
like reading manuals and learning the
spacecraft are you gonna do like a Rocky
4 Montage or
a lot of physical training and they're
like we didn't tell them to do it he's
just seems to want to film himself
shirtless in the snow it doesn't make
any houses always doing this I can't get
him to stop punching me
um so yeah hopefully uh
realistically
I like it but there's there's a physical
component to all of this and that's
that's really I mean that that's
fascinating it's also inspired in the
sort of civilians
can do this that's that's really
interesting yeah I mean this is and to
me this represents this and the other
commercial space you know uh private
space flight missions like this
represent really a turning point like
truly an inflection and again it's easy
for people to be cynical that
oh you know why are people wasting all
this money doing space flight stuff it's
like well I'm sure some people were
saying that same thing about you know
airplanes and and early Aviation going
like why are we I can't believe those
people are wasting the government's you
know funding these stupid planes and
stuff how's this ever going to benefit
me and nowadays like imagine if all the
planes just stopped working
would freak out like our economy would
collapse yeah it would suck you know and
I you know might be a long time before
we get to that reality with space fight
well I know if if spaceflight halted
today you know space assets uh all of
our you know on-orbit assets our life
would be crippled and I don't think
people realize that yeah so it's already
we're already reliant on it but now
we're getting to the point where it's
we're really turning that corner where
it's the average person alive today you
know if you're born uh you know now or
from now on I think there's a real
decent chance that by the time you pass
There's an opportunity to have flown in
space
yeah I mean I if I'm being honest I
still haven't lost the the feeling of
magic of flying in an airplane I often
catch myself thinking like how is this
real
how is it and like
the contrast of this incredible thing
that's incredibly safe flying through
the air taking off and Landing while
everyone else just looks bored
watching like I don't know uh some
romantic comedy on their phone with
Wi-Fi yeah so yeah it's just it's like
the contrast of that is like wow we're
we're incredible we're incredible as a
society and it's like we we develop some
amazing technology that improves almost
the measurably our quality of life and
then we take it for granted and now
still reach for the next thing and the
next thing and life becomes more
beautiful and complex and interesting
and yeah it's just the same stuff will
be uh happening oh yeah uh with space
travel oh it'll become mundane and
boring at some point the tough thing
about space travel of course
uh you know I don't even know if it's
such a giant leap over airplanes because
airplanes are already incredible but uh
the tough thing with space travel is the
destination right is the is the is the
landing on a whole lot of the worlds
well there's docking with with different
transport vehicles or the space station
or it's Landing elsewhere I mean it's
it's it it really really is incredible